so hello everybody i'm sitting here with
jp maxo
you probably have seen him on my channel
jp
is the editor of the symbolic world blog
and also
a contributor to that blog he's written
several really interesting articles he's
becoming
i would say a kind of bright star in the
world of symbolic interpretation
he also is able to provide
other aspects or ways of talking about
symbolism that i
don't have and so more philosophical
talking more about science and so i
really enjoyed talking with him
he recently wrote an article about
miracles which is something
that i've been hinting at once in a
while talking about miracles trying not
to talk too much about miracles because
i know
it's a stumbling stone for a lot of kind
of uh secular types or atheist types
but i knew that we had to kind of slowly
get there and so here we are
with that article i think we it's very
important to start talking about
miracles how they relate to notions of
emergence
uh and eminence how they participate in
reality how they are in a way
the let's say the the summit of reality
um
and so jp wrote this article about uh cs
lewis and verveiki
investigating miracles with verveicky
and c.s lewis i think i'm getting the
the the title wrong but the pattern is
right the pattern is right with the
title to draw
and so yeah all right so i'm looking
really for looking
forward to this conversation
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so i think to begin with maybe jp you
can give us the basic gist of your
article what your argument is
and then we can dive into it yeah so the
article itself
is um trying to summarize
the key insights of lewis in his book
miracles uh
using the metaphysics of uh
john raviki the the source of
metaphysics that he's been defending in
these discussions in our corner of the
internet because
the main key is that the way lewis used
to
talk about miracles back in his time was
sort of
set against the naturalism of his time
which was a
fairly simplistic kind of materialism
where nature is sort of
one big interlocked mechanical system
and
lewis's strategy to introduce miracles
in that
worldview was to take something closer
to us so take our rationality
and show that our rationality is not
something
that can be fit in that uh or
interlocking
old system and is a his argument is
something that actually john
made uh in his series and he also made
it in
the last discussion you had with him and
uh
where okay well if all that is uh
real ultimately is the mechanical level
of reality then
this will not make our rationality
real like our intellectual
concepts and so on will have to be
somehow reduced to something
mechanical but uh
this this makes not the ideas themselves
not our
theories themselves really makes only
the mechanical level real so it means
that our theory
which points to materialism doesn't fit
in the system so it's not rational so we
don't have to to believe it so it's
it's self-defeating and there's a blind
spot i think this is a blind spot we've
been all been pointing to for a while
which is
that a lot of materialists take for
granted they're the invisible part of
their world
they take for granted these theories as
if they don't even exist
and then they they use them to talk
about the material world and we've been
trying to say no look up
look at you have patterns that you use
to interpret
but you can't pretend as if those
patterns are physical because they're
not and then you also can't pretend that
they don't exist because
you're using them to interpret reality
yeah yeah yeah it's it's fascinating i
rewatched your
conference discussion with with jordan
and also with uh bet weinstein
and i was i was surprised to see how
strong
positivism is still going like how how
strong the
old-school modernist positivism is still
going in the sciences it's like we
because in philosophy itself this has
been sort of
debunked and it it it died i don't know
maybe 100 years ago like it
it it's it's really in dire straits and
people are going towards like
non-reductive kinds of physicalism that
i'm gonna
explain just a bit later in uh this
discussion but yeah definitely the
the blind spot is is real uh and there
are interesting reasons why it
it isn't clear yet why it doesn't
trickle down
to the the whole of academia but it's
definitely making its way i would say
because
in cognitive science like with you the
sort of metaphysics that you see john
put forward
is is totally aware of the the problems
of
uh modernistic positivism and he
he ends up with something that is much
more traditional
yeah and what is much more traditional
is is non-reductive kind of physicalism
we talked about it
in more details uh last time we had a
discussion
i think i i'd like to introduce it with
a
sort of a series of examples that become
more and more complex and make up their
way
progressively to miracles so that we
jump into the subject
sooner rather than than later
if uh you you look at let's say what
happens at the lowest
level of physics it's gonna look
super weird uh you're gonna
and you you often see physicists and uh
reductive physicalists say this sort of
thing and maybe blind
blindly and not recognizing the the
issue there but
they'll say for instance that from the
fundamental fields of probability at the
bottom of physics you can see
that particles just appear there
and if you leave it there it's a very
poor explanation of what is
going on it's super strange things don't
just pop out of
of fields of potential that's a strange
thing to say but the reason why you
accept it
the reason why we accept this strange
emergence is because we
also know the top-down pattern
that informs this potential we know that
there are certain laws of physics
that tell us that the probability that
certain particles will manifest
themselves out of
potential there uh and so this meeting
of
the the potential at the bottom layer of
physics and
the emanation of the the laws on the
potential
explains to us why the the particle
appears and because we have this this
pattern
to explain the emergence we were okay
with it
so you already have two layers of of
reality there and it just keeps getting
more and more complex as you go up the
different layers of reality
to explain the emergence of something
you always need to know the top-down
pattern
that informs it uh one layer that i find
really cool and useful
is the one that happens in our brains uh
if you were to look at what happens in
my brain as i'm saying these words
it would look completely insane like
it's so unprobable there are billions
and billions of neurons
which coordinate just the perfect ways
so that i
i i send the right signals to my muscles
and my lungs and so on my mouth so that
i just say these words
and this kind of coordination is is
insane if that's all you look at
like this is there's too much
possibility there for this to clear
correctly like it makes
it's insane but once you know
the emanation of the top-down pattern
there which is
my my fairly simple desire to say these
words
then this whole coherence makes sense
you can explain
the the bottom-up emergence by
simultaneously knowing the top-down
emanation of my my thought
so you have two layers of reality there
so and the way that for instance
non-reductive physicalist like john will
explain it is
that you cannot reduce my brain as a
whole
to let's it's individual constituents if
you try to do that you get the problem
of
like all of these possibilities that
don't cohere you need to explain that
there are constraints
that come from let's see my brain
considered as a whole and it it gets
even
more interesting than that because
modern
cognitive sciences will include also the
environment like the fact that
it's not just my brain it's my brain in
my body my environment and who knows how
far this goes
like it's this old structure this
pattern this abstract
uh this abstract spirit you can see that
informs that shapes the potential that
is emerging from
from my neurons okay so that this is
uh going from say the the cellular level
to the the level of of mind of an
individual person
yeah and so i mean to maybe synthesize
what you're saying you're saying that
when you look at something top bottom up
right you when you look at something
bottom up without understanding the
pattern which informs it then
it you can't make sense of it the sense
actually comes from the manner in which
they
they join together and they connect with
a top-down pattern
right and so if i look at a painting and
i look at all the all the
individual specks of paint on the
painting it's just a bunch of jumbled
specks of paint until i understand that
it's a painting of an apple and then
when i
when i know that it's a painting of an
apple then all of a sudden the jumbled
specks of paint make sense
yeah yeah find a reason to be there yeah
yeah and that's
it's it's one of the things i'm hoping
to bring out of this conversation is
i tend to speak um let's see from from
the outside
as like the old school philosophers like
aristotle or aquinas would do of
no seeing that there are layers of
patterns in the world
and the way that you tend to speak on
your channel is more as a
as a phenomenologist looking from how we
perceive things
as you know if i can um
we can take a simple object like you
took you took the painting uh
there you can we can look at it from the
first person perspective where
there there is a combinatorial explosion
of
of facts in the painting and i have to
take
this this all of these facts like this
layer of
infinity of facts and i have to abstract
the pattern from it so that i can then
understand
the this combinatorial explosion so this
happens in my
consciousness so that i can actually see
the the painting
so that i can see anything really i have
to make out the pattern behind this
emergence
and what i want to put forward here
is that this well this does really
happen
phenomenologically in my consciousness
it also happens in the
independently of me in the painting
itself like in the painting too
like the the whole structure of the
canvas is
informing all of the fundamental
particles or whatever
in the in the painting and they're
always changing like there's all kinds
of chemical interactions and
like photons are being going in and out
of the painting and so on so
the form of the painting which exists
even if i'm
even if no human is looking at it the
form of the painting still exists
and it is informing really the the
multitude
of uh atoms and particles and so on that
are in the painting
so the the meeting of emergence
elimination within my mind that allows
me to create the painting is also
occurring within the painting
in the meeting of the emergence from all
the particles and downwards from the
form of the opening
okay um so we talked about a few levels
and
if we keep going higher we'll get closer
and closer to
to to miracles the sort of top-down
causality the way that
ultimately what i want to get at and
it's what lewis was
getting at as well we want to say that
the way that i
can smoothly have uh causal influences
on my neurons for instance the way that
rationality can smoothly intermesh with
uh with the brain is the same kind of
smooth interaction
that god who is behind emergency
animation altogether
can have on creation but it's useful to
go through a few layers i think to to
get that this so
one example i like and i use in the
article is the example of the placebo
effect
because there what you have is a
situation where you need
the narrative frame to make sense of
what's going on because the other
patient who goes to see
his doctor and because he has serious
migraines for instance
and the the doctor ends him just a
flower pill and tells him that it's a
cure for
his uh his migraines and surprisingly
and this happens all the time
within like a day or two the patient is
completely ill there's
no more migraines you've had this this
weird coherence of
different chemical reactions within the
patient that really did like lower his
intracranial pressure and really did
lower stress enzymes and so on so
something
physical really happened but it doesn't
make sense if you try to explain
in terms of what the flower pill did in
his system because flour doesn't have
those causal powers like
flour doesn't do this but once you know
the
the story once you know the pattern once
you know the placebo effect
then this the this uh this all emergence
makes
makes sense once you know the top-down
elimination of the placebo effect
then you can make sense of the the
emergence of all the chemical reactions
within the patient that really did cure
uh
yeah i always i always use that example
too to talk about how the placebo effect
is the last remainder in a kind of
materialistic world one that they can't
totally get rid of
of how more traditional societies
thought of causality in terms of
top-down
causality and can help you understand
ritual your placebo can help you
understand ritual
help you understand magical acts can
help you understand how
you know uh exorcism all these things
you can understand through
understanding how let's say or at least
realizing that placebo is a real effect
in the world
yeah yeah so you just have to keep going
higher
yeah to get closer and closer to
miracles
um for instance i don't um talk about
this in miracles but you can
sorry i don't talk about this in the the
article but let's see what happens in a
in a church in a prayer group where lots
of people will prey
on on someone to heal something more
drastic than just a migraine you know
sometimes
this sort of thing works and it makes
sense once you know the narrative of you
know there's
there's all groups praying let's say to
a certain saint
and this whole story is very powerful
and it can
smoothly uh influence the emergence of a
real healing in the same way that i can
smoothly
uh influence the coherence of my neurons
when i think a certain thought
okay that makes sense all right so now
let's get to miracles here go forward
yeah one okay so following what we just
said
uh lewis will give us a useful
criterion to think about even just what
the miracle is and how to recognize them
the idea is okay now we're looking for
events that require not let's say the
the level of
explanation that you find in in certain
physical laws or
in even in a story that to explain
miracles
you'll need the highest level possible
you'll need
uh god himself with beyond emergence and
a nation altogether
you'll need something that uh seems to
okay so for one thing you need something
that looks
kind of alien that doesn't fit neatly
into the normal way that
emerges in the nation meet but at the
same time it's gonna have to make sense
it's gonna have to
be coherent in that once you know the
pattern it really does have to make
sense of everything below it
in the same way that once i know the
pattern of uh let's say
the laws of fundamental physics i really
need to to be explaining things
for it to be a legitimate explanation it
really needs to explain what you observe
in fundamental physics
or once i know uh the the level of
cognitive science thinking once
once let's say i i can detect your
intention and not just your neurons i
really need to be able to explain
how you behave i really need to be able
to explain like how
your your person and your cells will
interact with i really need to be able
to explain it
same thing will go on for for god and
miracles and that makes things obviously
more complex because now the claim is
is is huge uh we're claiming that once
we we take that frame to explain a
miracle it should make
all of reality more intelligible it
should make all of our emergence in the
nation more intelligible
once we know that a certain event was a
real miracle it was and it was called
biker
yeah and i think that that's really the
point we need to drive towards which is
that
when we talk about emanation when we
talk about the notion of
these different lev talk about
emergencies different levels emergent
emerging the question is what are they
emerging towards
and inevitably they're emerging toward
towards the different levels of unity
at the at the levels of which they're
jumping out of and so
you know you have multiplicity it jumps
into a one and then these ones join
together
they jump into they jump into another
one
but a way to understand that in a more
kind of phenomenological
way is to understand that they're
emerging towards identity they're
emerging towards name
they're emerging towards pattern uh and
they can also be emerging towards
narrative they
or at least how they fit inside stories
and how they fit inside facts
you know coming together in terms of
narrative and that's also
why you can understand how miracles
ultimately
end up like you said if you look at the
miracles they're not just random things
that happen without explanation which is
somehow how people want to characterize
them but they're
rather uh they're rather moments where
meaning shines like no other and so
christ walking on water is not just a
thing weird thing that happened that you
can't explain
it's a it's an event which happens and
which manifests the manner in which
like you said in which heaven and earth
you know come together it manifests the
manner in which
pattern can be above the chaos of
manifestation
and how it ends up ordering it when
christ you know tells for example the
the storm to stop
it's like how logos how meaning
will stabilize phenomena and so all the
miracles of christ and all the miracles
in scripture
are not just like freak things that
happen but are rather
super events that that help us make
sense
of this whole process of of uh emergence
and emanation
yeah and louis as a way of putting it i
think cause
it's okay i had been trying to write
something about miracles for a while but
i could never sort of pinpoint them
to something that was let's say
manageable because
like it explains too much and it's hard
to pin it down to something that you can
digest into just one article
uh and luisa's strategy is is very good
at this point
what he does is he focuses on
a few key aspects of nature
nature which is in our modern language
the meeting of emergency nation
we can recognize the miracles of christ
because they
they will be manifest they will be
shedding they will shed light on all of
those key aspects of nature
so the key aspect that luis thinks about
is first there is something we already
mentioned
the the the fact that nature
can uh actually this is this gets a bit
tricky
and i i only talk about it obliquely
lewis the way lewis was talking about
nature is a bit different
from the way that we talk about it today
because the naturalist now
agrees that there are different layers
of nature whereas the previous
naturalist only
saw it as sort of one big mechanical
layer yeah
but luis says that okay we see
in the world that there's an
intermission of uh
something that doesn't fit into that
system
into that one layer mechanical world
view uh
with namely the mind the mind doesn't
fit into
that one layer of mechanical causality
of the world so there has to be an
intermission of
mechanical uh reality with something
higher and we can see this in the
incarnation as well
there will be actually the all of
creation will be intermeshed with god
with outside operation altogether
and okay so this is one one aspect and
then you will
uh talk about three things uh you'll
talk about
selectiveness the fact that
and it's funny the way luis says it says
that the the
if you look at the way that nature
selects and also that god selects it can
somewhat hurt our democratic
sensibilities because
because in in all of uh the world for
all we know there's
there only seems to be like one planet
that has life on it and
in that life there's lots and lots of uh
uh
species and organisms that just dead end
that don't reproduce
uh it's very undemocratic and
the same thing goes on in in the
incarnation
because out of let's see all the planets
of course god selects the earth
to to internet it wouldn't make sense to
go on the moon for instance and then
you select just one people namely israel
and then you'll select just one girl
namely mary
to fashion a body for himself and then
it will be
sort of all on the shoulders of christ
until he found the church and so on
but this this selection well it can
seem sort of evil uh from the outside
because i mean nature
is falling in certain respects there
there really are bad aspects to
selectiveness the way
that it exists right now but in using
this
uh the incarnation shows us that
selectiveness doesn't have to be
evil like at its roots uh it it can be
good
provided that for instance israel is
selected but is selected to save the
whole planet
it's it's elected to save ultimately all
of reality and it will do so through
very difficult trials like in many ways
it's much harder to be
an israelite than to be a someone from
some other tribe and then similarly for
for mary of christ
who were selected but they were selected
to uh save the entire world
so yeah and i think that's the mystery
let's say the difference between
christianity because
every every type of empire every type of
government will have that process
where you have a chief you have people
above and people below and so
the selectiveness is inevitable those
who think that it that it can be
you know communists who think that you
can avoid it end up creating
uh you know an insane parody of of that
very selective process
yeah and so it's inevitable and the the
mystery that christianity offers is that
the selectives never the true
selectiveness happens
through how the thing that is selected
then sacrifices
itself for that which is it is selected
out of which is the huge difference
between christianity and other
another aspect that anyways continue
with the musical part yeah but that's
true that's where i was heading
because the lewis then focuses on
vicariousness
the idea that when the these selected
devote themselves to the unselected you
see something that's good
and that actually redeems several
aspects of nature again
uh prince because no living thing
survives on its own like it doesn't
happen in nature everything eats
something else there are even parasites
and all kinds of very bad interactions
by which something survives only by
being a parasite on something else but
this vicariousness can also be
great it's also the instance of let's
say the child depending on his mother
or the fact that we depend on christ it
can actually be beautiful for
to see some people sacrifice themselves
and for us to accept this in gratitude
it redeems an aspect that is fundamental
to nature this always happens
everything that exists exists because of
something else
except god but this gets complicated
let's see everything in nature uh
exists because of something else and
then the the third point
is the pattern of death and rebirth
which is also like
universal throughout nature everything
let's say
everything that we see around us will
will die
and then lewis has a a very beautiful
way of putting it that i had never seen
before
he says that by letting satan introduce
death into the world
god was doing a master move
in sorry master strategist move because
by letting satan introduce death into
the world
it allowed christ to die precisely to
reading the world
so it introduced something in nature
which is that everything we see
dies but also it allows us to use that
and turn it into glory to turn death
into glory
because right now
and we can see it even within nature
that there are aspects of this pattern
that
it's not just all tragic all the time
the fact that certain trees die for
instance is also what allows the entire
forest to
to remain alive like this pattern can be
beautiful and of course
its highest expression is in christ
itself and the way he sacrifices himself
for the the entire world
and is reborn so these these are the
the few patterns that's that lewis
selects and i think it makes convincing
that
in the incarnation which is the process
where god
selects uh to incarnate himself
to then re-emerge in in in the church
that will remain the entire world
this is so coherent with the way that we
see
nature work at its most fundamental
level that
it makes miracles very plausible uh
and this is at the highest level of the
incarnation so this is the the
the biggest pattern and the individual
miracles of christ
will make sense within that overarching
pattern
so he notices
that you can break up the miracles of
christ into
two categories there's miracles of the
old creation and miracles of the
new creation so miracles of the the old
creation
are the miracles that focus sort of in
one precise moment patterns that
already occur on the grand scale
patterns that god already does at the
great scale
so for instance the
the the virgin birth is an example of
a cosmic pattern just focused at one
particular point
where in in the virgin birth god
creates non-violently anybody for
himself such an atom
nothing there's there's a spermatozoon
missing and yet he creates a body for
himself in there
and this seems crazy for us once we see
it this way at our
human level but the same thing happens
at the cosmic scale like
all the time the fact that the world is
created out of nothing i know for
instance
it's crazy too it's just like people
people believe in
people think the virgin birth is insane
but they believe in the big bang it's
like okay
so everything comes out of nothing but
you don't like the idea that
that that let's say that that miracle
would show you how the reality works but
you believe that's how reality works
interesting and it's the same for a
bunch of other miracles that christ does
that just replicate old patterns
a cool one is the miracle at the wedding
of cana where it turns water into mine
and this is in the normal pattern for
wine that's put into certain jars
by the work of human ends to turn into
wine it happens all the time
and it's crazy just when you think about
it that this works it's
it's insane that something as bland as
water by the fruit of
human hands can become it's a euphoric
liquid it's it's weird but we only
notice this
when it's contracted into one moment
where a god
himself tells people to go fetch some
water from a well put it in
some jars and then pour it so after
after
working water uh into
some earthen vessel or some rock vessel
it will become
wine it again focuses something that
always happens in creation
into one point uh
you could also uh talk about let's see
the multiplication of the loaves and
fishes
this happens all the time of course as
well where fishes multiply
all the time and when we plant seeds it
grows again yeah yeah so so it always
happens and it's it's also
one pattern that is strange when you
think about it it sort of opens your
eyes to
just how beautiful and kind of crazy it
is that food can multiply this way
but so so what christ does
is he and one way to see it maybe is as
a as a
microcosm because christ then christ is
becoming
the end of creation christian was in
rebellion and then god comes down to
become the end of creation once again to
bring creation into into himself into
write prayer
right worship you can say and by doing
this
he takes something that is a pattern
that is
on the broader scale the way that christ
creates the world in general
he brings it into a microcosm so that it
can be the head of creation so the seed
that then
will bring our creation back into
himself and it was super important that
he did those old creation miracles
because it allows us today to recognize
him as
as god as the creator of this world but
it also allowed people to do the same at
the time and it was a
part it was an important part of the
story like it's what allowed people to
recognize him as god back then
and some people followed him and
lots of people just wanted to kill him
because of it and that was
an important part of the story it was
important that he
the miracles that he did were
uncontrovertible like people couldn't
just dismiss him if he hadn't done
miracles like
not that many people would have wanted
to kill him but he he was really
despised because people couldn't dismiss
him they didn't like what he was saying
but they couldn't
like dismiss his his powers they
couldn't dismiss the fact that he was
clearly doing
something miraculous and that was
a way that luis puts it that is really
beautiful i think is
he it's not as if god was coming and
just sort of wrecking random miracles
like you see in some
pagan myths sometimes there's weird
stuff that happens just doesn't
miracles don't seem to make sense but
what you see rather in christ miracles
it's more like a king coming into his
own kingdom a king doing some things
that will sort of seamlessly fit into
creation in the same way that my my mind
seamlessly informs my brain for instance
okay yeah that makes sense yeah it makes
sense one of the things that i like is
to
is to really use that very pattern of
let's say uh emergence and emanation to
look at the miracles of christ
because like i said i think that every
single miracle
of christ bring together or show us
the secret of this process they show us
how in
in old testament terms how heaven and
earth meet together
and so the idea that christ heals the
sick is exactly that
the notion of a sick person is someone
whose parts don't fit together
that's what a sick person is they have
different aspects of themselves and
they're not
properly fit they're not properly
working together and so the word the
seed the light
comes from above and and and
brings it together re-manifest like
re-imprints the normal pattern on
on that broken vessel and so that's one
of the types of miracles christ does
like i said walking on water
uh healing stopping the storm all of
these are the same
they're all the same thing they're all
you know something from above coming
down
and and calming bringing order
making sense of that which is which is
below
yeah and i think that every really every
single miracle that christ
does the same with a you know something
as crazy as
uh this notion of the the the healing of
the woman that bleeds right
and so here is a woman who's leaking
stuff like it does not clear exactly
what's going on but
she's leaking and so it's like she's not
contained
and so christ comes and just by touching
christ
then she becomes contained like her
identity and her body kind of
come together and she stops to to to
lose herself in the
on the world she starts to spread
herself out on the ground you could say
and so every single miracle that christ
does is just
manifesting in a super manner in like a
in a super condensed manner
the very process of how reality shows
itself to us
yeah yeah and one thing that lewis
brings out and we touched on a few of
those for instance in the
walking on water and other miracles like
there would be uh the
the transfiguration and also the raising
of uh
of the dead and the the resurrection of
christ himself
lewis calls those new creation miracles
in that they're not just the old
patterns
of of creation not just the old ways in
which heaven and earth meet
like multiplying loaves and fishes and
turning water into one and so on those
are all patterns those are the old ways
in which heaven and earth meet
but in the incarnation christ doesn't
just
sort of come down to show us the
patterns of the old creation the purpose
is also to bring all of creation back
into himself and in doing that this will
include
sort of setting all of the the the
powers and principalities right this
will involve
you can say rewriting the the
regularities rewriting the patterns that
told in nature
in modern language you can see rewriting
the laws of nature
and you can see that christ was smoothly
moving from
the old christian miracles to the new
creation miracles in his ministry so
it's towards the end that
he raises lazarus from the dead that he
is transfigured
and also uh that he is ultimately
himself
resurrected those are all cases where
it's not only that in the old creation
heaven and earth meat that patterns
and uh matter can need to form
uh loaves fishes and so on in the new
creation miracles
which points to the new creation where
heaven and earth will meet
even more directly like the the
relationship will be more intense mind
will be
able to inform matter more so that's an
instance of
walking on water where it's not just
that our minds
can inform our bodies like our our minds
will be able to inform
even like water even other aspects of
creation that are chaotic and unruly at
the moment
the transfiguration is another instance
where christ's body was shining and
like close to moses and elijah
this idea that you can sort of be in
tune with
older patterns and bring them back into
a new and richer and transformed body
and then same thing with christ's body
after the resurrection
it's not just that his head was able to
govern his body and that he didn't die
like lazarus or the other
uh one or two people erase from the dead
i'm not sure so it's not just that
it reverses the normal course of nature
the let's say the second law of
thermodynamics by
re-uh by recreating
order that was lost his body was also
able to do a bunch of stuff that
he couldn't do before uh he can sort of
go through walls he can kind of appear
and disappear all kinds of words things
happen
that showed that the the purpose of the
incarnation
was to ultimately change the walls of
nature so to set creation all right
after i after you can see that the
patterns of nature
had fallen and that the the the patterns
that i laid out before were wrong
christ lays them out uh right again so
in uh
showing us that in using the patterns of
uh selectiveness vicariousness death and
rebirth
christ shows us that at their deepest
nature they were meant for good
and yeah actually sets them for good in
the
in the incarnation like he he really
does use selectedness uh
vicariousness and death and rebirth to
set those patterns set nature
right again and it's been unfolding for
2000 years obviously and it's not
perfect
but it's it's already better than it was
2 000 years ago
well that's that's at least what we
that's what we think but
um and so i think that i i think that
we've probably gone for for quite a
while but i think that
at least what i kind of take out of this
is
really understanding miracles it's
almost like reversing the way that
our kind of new atheist type of person
sees
miracles which is that instead of seeing
miracles as the freak thing you use to
disprove religion
it's almost as if the it's the contrary
the miracle becomes the very key
to showing you how reality works it
actually becomes
shining moments that are so bright and
there's something about that
where the pattern appears so strongly in
the miracle that it becomes difficult
for us to see the secondary causes
it's like i can't if you ask me like
okay how is it that jesus walked on
water it's like
i don't i don't know first of all i
wasn't there i can't tell you
but well like what i can tell you is
when i see that story
and i hear the story of christ walking
on water i recognize
that it's showing me how reality works
it's it's manifesting to me
that some very deep secrets of how the
world exists and also how
we are called to exist in christ that is
we are also called to
through our own like our attachment to
god and our logos to
inform and to stabilize the reality
around us whether it's our relationships
our families
and also the physical world in terms of
in terms of you know in terms of
building things and creating cities and
creating civilization
and so and so then at that point the
secondary causes
it's like you don't care what they are
and i know a lot of people will get
angry that i say that
but i don't know what the secondary
causes are and i don't it doesn't really
bother me it doesn't i don't ask that
question
just just like you said in the way that
i also don't understand the secondary
causes
of how my own thought works i don't
understand how all the neurons align
and how all the the the you know
all the the cells you know whatever all
this these things that's going on
at lower levels i don't understand it
and i don't attend to that
because if i try to attend to that too
much
then i start to lose what exactly this
is about and i've seen this in
in in uh kind of modern approaches to
miracles where
they tried to kind of explain the
secondary causalities i heard crazy you
crazy things even christians saying
crazy things about
how you know like when the israelites
cross the red sea that you know at the
red sea at that point is really thin
it's really not it's really shallow at a
certain time of year and if there was a
really strong wind maybe
it could like split open the sea and
then they could walk through
and i was like dude you're losing the
plot
here like i don't know what you're i
don't care what you're talking about
you're losing
you don't you stop to understand what
this miracle is about and how
it manifests the very pattern of
creation by pulling dry earth out of
water
through uh the spirit coming down from
above it's like if you can't if once you
start attending too much of the
secondary causes
you'll stop to see how it's showing you
the pattern of reality yeah yeah and
yeah i was hoping we would get to this
because there's something i want to
stress at this point and
it's not just the pragmatic move of
focusing on the pattern
focusing on the iron level pattern
rather than focusing on the
the multiplicity it's like i've seen
this
in um in reading papers in philosophy of
mind like it would be
technically wrong for instance for me to
try to explain
why you're uh what you're talking to me
and zoom right now
if i was to look at the the precise
neuronal events that occurred within
your brain like it would be technically
wrong
and we can do this using counterfactuals
so let's see
if um uh i i say okay so
if rather than the neuronal
configuration a
you uh you add that something else
if this new configuration didn't happen
would you still have come
to talk to me and zoom and of course the
answer is is yes like
you wouldn't have done it in the precise
way let's say that you moved this
morning at whatever time
but the overarching pattern of you
coming to zoom and talking to me
this is still true the real explanation
is at the level of your your intention
at the level of your your your
consciousness and not at the level of
your individual neurons
yeah and i think that's really important
to understand because
the because of the multiplicity and
because the possibility of difference at
the lower level
if you start to notice the differences
at the lower level
then then you then you don't realize
that
multiplicity different multiplicities
can can manifest the same pattern like a
pattern can
manifest it so for example like if you
take two cups and you
focus on how they're different and you
start looking at all the different chips
and the different things in the paint
and everything
and that's what you're talking about
it's like okay dude both of those are
cups stop
focusing on the yeah on the details
because you're going to forget what
they're what's going on
and he's got his christmas cup too look
at that it's not even halloween yet
because yeah we had really christmas
weather here in quebec
yeah it's going away now but anyways
it's gonna come back yeah even this cup
like at every instant it's different
like it's exchanging neurons and
whatever there's all kinds of vibrations
that are happening there and it's still
the same
that all the multiplicity at the lower
level doesn't remain the unicity at the
level of the cup
so i think the same thing happens in
in the miracles of christ for instance i
think a great illustration of this is
the fact that we have four accounts of
his resurrection
and they're somewhat different and i
think this is telling us that
it doesn't matter like which precise
physical manifestation
happened of the pattern what matters is
the pattern of the resurrection was
there
like this is what matters it could have
been like either of the accounts it
could have been something different as
long as the same pattern holds
the manifest the precise manifestation
isn't what matters any more than
when i'm speaking to you now what
matters is the thoughts behind what i'm
saying
not the precise neural configuration
there could be a million different
neural configurations that would give
the same manifestation of my thought
yeah and there's
there was you know even in the early
church there was a temptation
to synchronize the gospel there was a
desire some people had the desire to
take the four gospels and then kind of
you know streamline them and then make
one gospel that everybody would follow
and the church fathers
refused that they refused that process
and i think that
there is a hint in there there's a
suggestion
of what we said which is that if we that
multiplicity comes together in unity and
even sometimes things that look
contradictory or look like they're that
they're not the same
that that it's the pattern which brings
them together and so
the thing that brings the four gospel
accounts together is christ
christ is beyond the gospels christ you
know when
when some people call god call the bible
the word of god
got to be very careful the word of god
is not the gospels
it's what's above it it's christ which
is which is holding together these
different
sometimes even different uh accounts of
his life
yeah yeah and i i can't
i i i want to use that occasion to come
back let's see on especially the very
old miracles in the bibles
because it happens sometimes that i i've
seen it i've seen it in q and a's where
people ask you about let's say the
exodus
and so on and i think with what we've
said we have the key
to answer even like some some of the
more reluctant people um
when let's see it says that moses split
the water
and you alluded to this miracle earlier
i don't know what the
like the precise physical manifestation
of the pattern was
and it doesn't matter what matters is
the pattern there was a physical
manifestation of the pattern like it
it's necessary i think that's important
too it's not
people because they don't they stop to
realize that symbolism is the pattern of
reality they always
want to tend to go towards oh it's an
imaginary thing well what do you mean
what do you it's like it's just a story
people told
no it's like that's the pattern of
reality they're talking about
how the world manifests itself it's just
maybe not in the way you would want it
to be described but you know
yeah i think it's uh when let's say you
often talk about this on your channel
the way you
you often talk phenomenologically and
it's sort of implicit that when you
describe the way that we humans perceive
patterns this is how we
we contract stories in the past making
them more and more mythological
the fact that we do this in our
phenomenology reflects something that is
real in the outside world outside of our
phenomenology
so whatever happened during the exodus
like
i don't know if it was i don't know what
the physical manifestation was
but whatever happened it was crazy like
it's as crazy as uh what you imagine
when you imagine
moses splitting the waters and it's the
the pattern that matters
the precise physical manifestation isn't
isn't a big deal it's important that it
happened
but the precise one doesn't and
whichever manifestation happen it's
going to blow our minds anyways
yeah and it was important enough to in
the
eyes of the israelites to seal for them
what was happening
and to understand that they were going
through a recreation that they were
moving out of the flood that they were
finding new land again
that all the patterns that they had
learned as children in terms of the
story of the
the flood of noah what what is what was
happening to them
and it was happening in a dramatic
manner that was about to launch
into i mean they didn't know at the time
but was going to launch into basically
the most influential story in the in
all of humanity like these stories that
have basically
molded all of all of civilization all of
western civilization
and is also not just western
civilization but is also
molding other civilizations through
through the kind of the spread of
western ideas
yeah yeah and even let's see if you try
to look at the story of
judaism without like by naturalizing
miracles it's not going to be less weird
it's so strange like the kind of laws
they have and circumcision and all those
rituals and
like what do they have against idolatry
like the only ones who care about this
stuff
they're such a weird people like no
matter what genesis you come
uh to use to understand them it's always
going to be strange and it it's always
going to
express the same pattern as the
israelites themselves described in the
oldest old testament yeah
all right jp i think i think we've gone
around miracles and we've created a few
headaches
to some people watching this i imagine
the process and so all right guys
the the comment section is open i know
it's gonna be crazy and there's going to
be a lot of stuff going on
so uh so go nuts and we'll have fun
reading the comments
and uh and maybe engaging on some
further time on this
as well and i want to tell everybody to
go to the symbolicworld.com
check out the blog the articles that are
being put out are all
very good uh and jp's article especially
so so check that out and stay tuned for
more discussion on symbolism with
other writers on the blog as well i hope
you enjoyed our discussion on miracles
as you know everything we do here on the
symbolic world
is thanks to your support so you can
check out the website the
symbolicworld.com
support to find out how you can help us
out
there are also ways to purchase the
products that i've designed which are
based on traditional imagery
i've just put out some recent patterns
based on a
celtic slash anglo-saxon vision of
the four beasts of ezekiel which are
interpreted as evangelists
and also i put out a dragon all-over
pattern
for a more subtle look so once again
thank you for giving me the possibility
of doing this and i will talk to
everybody very soon